[Musique]
bonsoir la franche comté est la première
zone boisée de france depuis quelques
mois les arbres de notre région
souffrent des pluies acides provoquées
notamment par l'industrie mais aussi par
la circulation automobile
on parle de plus en plus de pots
catalytiques de filtres pour cheminées
d'usiné une mesure toute récente vient
d'être prise elle sera applicable à
partir du week-end prochain déjà utilisé
en grèce et en italie la circulation des
voitures privées
un week-end sur deux les forêts
vosgiennes et franc comtoise summer au
banc des accusés les plus acides cette
pollution a déjà causé de nombreux
dégâts dans d'autres pays industralisés
comme l'allemagne
mais c'est en grèce et en italie que des
mesures énergiques ont été prises pour
limiter les dégâts avec notamment les
pots catalytiques
mais surtout l'interdiction d'utiliser
une voiture particulière un week-end sur
deux pour la première fois en franche
comté et dans les vosges cette mesure
sera appliquée dès le week-end prochain
c'est la plaque minéralogique de votre
véhicule qui servira de repère une
semaine ce seront les numéros pairs qui
pourront partir en week-end la semaine
suivante les numéros impairs un ensemble
de mesures qui ne fait pas l'unanimité
chez les usagers
[Musique]
pas du tout ces scandales
un titre aux as cependant mal pourquoi
autres c'est normal faut s'habituer
c'est pour uniquement à limiter la
pollution est ce que vous pensez que
chez nous en suisse
vous êtes suisse et se seraient déjà en
suisse non pas encore mais on a une
situation il ya dix ans c'était un
taudis le dimanche de rouler ses
habitués aussi à cette situation la
faute peut-être à faire une fois les 5
pourquoi pas total matière de revoir la
chose
non pas du tout complètement
inadmissible
moi ça me dérange pas remarqué j'ai pas
de perdre la semaine prochaine j'en ai
eu une la semaine d'après donc avec un
peu de chance si ça tombe bien ça de
réalisme enfin ça me dérange pas est ce
que vous trouvez ça normal pour limiter
la pollution
ah ben non non je celui qui veut rouler
le week-end mon jeu je trouve ça tout à
fait normal qu'ils roulent le week end
voilà
complètement aberrant
râper du monte à 10h30
surtout quand on est dans le droit
toupet l'assurance de la vignette on
paye déjà les sens assez cher et
[Musique]
franchement on
je reçois une el béchir l'italie en
grèce
pour écouter venez pas me raconter des
conneries s'il vous plaît mais moi je
suis en france je travaille je suis ici
depuis cinq ans je m'excuse je suis venu
ici bosser je n'ai amené pas du tout ce
genre d'histoire parce que on a déjà
fait l'essai en italie en italie c'est
pas marché je vois pas pourquoi dans un
pays comme la france un pays qu'ils
soient qui sait kiev soit disant
civilisés par camille des régionales
je ne paie pas de mettre ce genre
d'histoire je n'ai pas ne peut pas
admettre notre région servira donc de
test national n'oubliez pas ce week-end
les voitures avec un numéro impair ne
devront pas roulé la police a déjà reçu
des directives
[Musique]